Fox News and Dominion voting systems
have settled Dominion's
1.6 billion dollar defamation suit
against Fox News they have settled it at
787 million dollars just as the trial
was starting this will require and did
require Fox News in writing to concede
that they got some things wrong AKA lied
but it will not require them to make
on-air apology this is not about Free
Speech this is about a responsibility
for a public platform the size of Fox
News
not to defame others and then secondly
there's the question of wow now that
they've paid nearly 800 million to
settle a defamation claim in which they
lied to Their audience maybe they will
lose their audience but of course I
don't think that that's going to happen
the Fox News viewer actually sees Fox
News as the victim here by and large